[Applaudissements]
les plaisirs wa peuvent exulter ce
dimanche 21 avril les jaune et bleu ont
réussi à se maintenir lors de l'ultime
journée du championnat de fédérale 2
après une victoire 35 à 28 face au havre
à domicile très content très heureux du
contenu
de ce qu'ils ont fait les garçons
gros investissement gros combat et en
même temps on n'a pas oublié de notre
volume de jeu on n'a pas oublié de jouer
donc ça s'est très très bien
l'équipe termine finalement la 9e place
du classement et jouera une troisième
saison consécutive dans ce championnat
de fédérale 2 le staff et les joueurs
retient droit avant tout la progression
de l'équipe sur cette saison
effectivement ils n'étaient pas là par
hasard que le maintien qui avait eu lieu
l'année dernière c'était pas non plus un
hasard
et du coup on a vraiment travaillé
positivement et on a pu faire progresser
encore une fois les gars sur ce qu'on
espère et sur ce qu'on aime voir sur un
terrain de rugby c'est à dire du jeu
quoi on est un petit club qui arrive à
résister à ce niveau là et c'est
vraiment difficile aujourd'hui avec les
structures concurrentes qui a et voilà
je crois qu'on a pu montrer qu'on était
vraiment une bande de copains passionnés
amoureux de ce club
et voilà je crois que c'est le coeur
qu'à gagner surtout aujourd'hui il bande
de copains qui n'a peut-être pas fini de
nous surprendre les joueurs auront à
coeur de finir en milieu de tableau de
fédérale 2 la saison prochaine
en attendant le club peut savourer
[Applaudissements]